and Alabama senator Doug Jones has been
talking with local authorities in the
devastated area he's with us here now in
studio 57 senator good morning I'm so
sorry to hear about your state and
what's happened to the people there what
can you tell us about the community
where this happened you know we're not
far from Auburn University but this is a
pretty rural area it's a small town to
small town three small towns in the area
these are small structures they're going
to be mobile homes they're going to be
small structures it's also a flat
terrain so you're not going to have a
lot of basements which is the typical
storm shelter for folks in Alabama this
is not the first time we've seen things
like this but in this area it can be
particularly devastate so there used to
this kind of this kind of weather
Alabama is always getting prepared in
the spring we always have tornadoes you
know in 2011 we lost over 200 people in
a string of some 60 tornadoes so people
get ready and they understand how do
people recover from this when you lose
your home it's very difficult first of
all we got a great first responder team
down there IEMA does an unbelievable job
this is not their first time so they'll
do a great job of rebuilding federal
authorities state authorities will be in
there I think the most important thing
right now is search-and-rescue going
through there first thing this morning
to try to find anybody that might be
alive as well as anybody that might not
be I understand they use drones with
heat-seeking material try and find it
there's life drones they use humans
every way possible to try to get into
those areas fortunately this is a fairly
confined area so they can get in there
fairly quickly all right what are you
doing people about how it's going though
I think it's going fine yeah you know
again you've got a you got to let the
weather pass you got to let things going
on
I think the key right now is for other
people to kind of stay way there's a lot
of people that want to see just stay
away a lot of first responders get in
there senator Jones thank you